but it continues because uh the ladies
they not they weren't all fully
satisfied with the Gavin Newsome answer
so there must be somewhat better in the
party than Kevin Newsom I think him I
still think Pete Buda judge is really
great whenever I've seen him speak would
the country put a gay president
I don't care he's the best one
he's really great
homophobic incredible analysis by the
blonde there nobody knows her name does
anyone know her name I mean we play
clips of The View every day nobody knows
her name literally nobody knows um it
doesn't even matter but he's just great
I hear him talking he's just great
first off the gay thing is nobody cares
literally nobody cares anymore he's
married to a dude big deal if he was a
great Transportation secretary let's say
our infrastructure was just being
rebuilt at an incredible rate right now
when things like the the horrific
disaster in East Palestine happened that
the government got in there and cleaned
up real quick or whatever's still going
on in Maui as we speak the disaster over
there from the fire it's like if the
government was functional and this guy
was in charge of a lot of things and
doing it well then maybe there would be
a case maybe there would be a case to be
made but basically what she's saying is
he's gay he's gay and I like him when he
speaks that's not that does not make you
you know what Connor you know what they
did they put her name on the screen for
me I'm not even going to read it now I
know what her name is okay that's just
fine nobody needs to know her name
somehow she's like a completely erasable
character on that ridiculous program I'm
not even going to say it does not matter
anyway the point is Biden is not running
the show and it's just a matter of how
long can they string them along nobody
believes in Kamala Harris Gavin Newsom
is an evil lizard person Pete is gay
myself
[Music]